[Applause]
many of you probably think all the
countries in the Arabian Peninsula are
insanely wealthy right I mean this is
the region of the world where Qatar
Dubai and the rest of the oil monarchies
are after all nonetheless right in this
region of the planet is a country that
is extremely poor the place with a GDP
per capita lower than that of Tanzania
or Senegal the name of this country is
Yemen and it is currently going through
a civil war that has lasted 42 years
[Music]
and look this this it's no small war in
fact the war in Yemen is the Arabian
equivalent to the war in Vietnam
here we find two of the biggest powers
in the Muslim world supporting different
sides of the conflict on the one hand we
have the Yemeni government supported by
Saudi Arabia and all their allies
including the United States and on the
other side there are the revolutionaries
backed by Iran and between these two
sides there is the Yemeni branch of - or
these so-called Ansar al-sharia movement
now if you've been subscribed to visual
politic for a while you already know
that Saudi Arabia has the third best
equipped army in the entire world thus
they have the support of American drones
and the armies of neighbouring countries
they have more than 180 state-of-the-art
combat jets and three hundred thousand
soldiers armed with the best weapons on
the other side they have less than half
that number of soldiers and the weapons
they are armed with are far from modern
now so this seems like a pretty unequal
fight right well in that case it might
surprise you to learn that Saudi Arabia
is losing this war Saudi Arabia says
prepared for ceasefire in Yemen if
Houthis agree and so now you might
wonder how exactly is this possible how
is it possible to explain why one of the
most advanced armies in the world can't
beat a bunch of guerrillas well today
we're visual politic while we're gonna
answer that question but before we get
into any of that let's have a look at
the history
who is who Yemen the first thing we need
to understand is that this is not the
first time Yemen has had a civil war in
fact this is the third one in just 25
years Yemen is a country divided by both
ideology as well as religion indeed
before the 1990s Yemen was split into
two different countries
[Music]
we had South Yemen with a communist
governments and then there was North
Yemen who had a pro Saudi government and
the guy you are seeing on the screen now
Ali Abdullah Saleh who was the president
of the north started ruling over the
entire country from its capital the city
of Sanaa
[Music]
as you can imagine Salah is one of those
politicians who considers democracy and
human rights to be well pretty optional
four years into his new country's
history and the former southern
communist leaders started an uprising
against the less governments this war
only lasted a few months and the new
government won with the assistance of
the Saudis a decade later in 2004 Yemen
had further anti-government turmoil this
time the opposition was a rebel group of
Shia Muslims remember their name because
they are important for the war that's
going on today they are called the
Houthi rebels but again these Salah
governments beat down this uprising
[Music]
in 2011 with the Arab Spring in full
swing the citizens rebelled against
sulla again but this time Scylla left
power with his Prime Minister mansur
al-hadi this new president found himself
in control of a terribly weak
government's further al-qaeda were
working on destroying the country and
during all of this well the protesters
they kept protesting now do you remember
those who theme rebels that we talked
about just a moment ago well they came
back but this time they were more
powerful and had a lot of support and
this explains why in 2014 they managed
to take over the government
[Music]
okay so now you might be wondering what
did al-hadi do well he left capital and
moved to the city of Arden in the south
of the country to start a provisional
government
[Music]
now remember here that Saudi Arabia is a
Sunni Muslim country band well who is
the biggest enemy of Sunni Muslims oh
yeah that would be these Shia Muslims
these are exactly the people who have
conquered the capital of Yemen and this
explains why the Saudis are so keen on
supporting al Hardy and his provisional
government in Aden then finally we also
have - aka Islamic state in the mix as
well who are well an enemy of both sides
all right so now we have the Houthi
rebels and their supporters the Houthis
are Shia Muslims and therefore they are
friends with Iran on the other hand
al-hadi he is in Arlen and he is
supported by the Saudis and the Saudis
will do whatever it takes to ensure that
Iranian influence in Yemen is minimized
you probably remember from one of our
previous videos that Saudi Arabia and
Iran are diehard enemies and thus in
2015 another Yemeni civil war started
[Music]
a natural fortress when we think about
Saudi Arabia we think of a big desert
with clean sand and dunes Yemen it's
rather different it is a country full of
mountains almost as high as the Rockies
in the United States some peaks are
higher than 3600 meters
[Music]
all of this makes it really hard to
transport a big army no matter how
well-equipped atures for instance the
Saudis they utilize a tank model called
the m1a1 Abrams this is sort of like the
BMW of tanks now imagine a convoy of
these machines crossing a path where
they have to travel in single file you
would just need a few guerrilla warriors
with an RPG seven rocket launcher to
destroy an entire battalion the RPG 7 is
a rocket launcher that you can see on
video games such as call of duty and it
has a market price of around three
thousand US dollars the m1 Abrams tank
on the other hand costs around six
million dollars
[Music]
but well not only that as we said at the
start of this video the Saudi Coalition
has over 180 combat jets and also
American drones but there is a further
problem here in the landscape full of
mountains and caves it really is easy to
hide from these drones not even the
state-of-the-art radars can see in
detail what's inside of the caves and of
course the Houthi warriors they know the
battlefield like the back of their hands
and they know where all the good hiding
places are in many cases they can travel
from one village to another without
being exposed to any of the drone radars
they can also hide their weapons inside
these caves but that is still not all
even though these guerrillas that have
no Hummers or other modern vehicles they
have something better they have animals
oh yes you heard that right
in those high mountain areas the most
effective way to transport something is
by using donkeys or camels
[Music]
so in other words the only way of
tracking the movements of these
guerrilla warriors is by having people
behind their lines
now we're not exactly talking
double-oh-seven like spies here that
rather local citizens who are willing to
help or soldiers who are close to enemy
lines
all right so even with these problems
you might still be wondering how the
Saudis are getting beaten the scales
seem to still be tips pretty far in
Saudi Arabia's favor aid to motivated
army now many of you might think that
the political system of the country has
nothing to do with the way they
organized their army and conduct war
well actually in a country like Saudi
Arabia they are really connected in an
absolute monarchy like they have in
Saudi Arabia the royal house cannot
trust their army their main obsession is
keeping control over the entire military
from the top all the way to the bottom
this is why the decision-making power is
slower than in any other army
let's have a look at a hypothetical
example here because it's all
illustrative asset let's imagine a
soldier discovers a machine-gun nest
that is say 300 meters out in western
armies such as the American or British
one that soldier can easily ask for
reinforcements by radio usually he or
she would go alongside with another
soldier from the Air Force who can give
the exact coordinates to a pilot nearby
in a matter of minutes a combat jet is
bombing the machine-gun nest now let's
consider the Saudi army first of all our
soldier would have to tell the sergeant
and that sergeant would have to speak to
someone higher up and but the time that
decision has really reached someone he
can actually make the decision it's been
longer than an hour for 60 minutes here
are the difference between neutralizing
an enemy position and losing a soldier
[Music]
and the same goes for military training
most Saudi officials come from the royal
houses and they didn't go through any
sort of academic military training they
got their position due to pure nepotism
and this means well a distinct lack of
knowledge and skills the same goes for
normal soldiers as well as you probably
know in most of these oil monarchies
most of the native citizens work as
civil servants with sky-high salaries
they really don't know anything about
discipline or hard work so let's look at
an example in the video here you can see
that they don't even know how to protect
a tank with infantry
[Music]
and don't forget that inside that tank
it's very difficult to see the outside
this is why a basic principle of war is
that you always want to have soldiers
walking around the tank so that they can
see if something is firing upon it
this really is war 101 nevertheless the
Saudis missed that class and this
explains why it is so easy to destroy
their tanks with such cheap weaponry
this is have a look at this other video
here you can see how someone gets close
enough to you a tank to put a bomb on it
[Music]
on the other hand surprisingly the
Houthi rebels have a much more Western
management system small groups can react
quickly and they don't need to go all
the way up through the hierarchy thus
their motivation is way higher because
they don't have the option of just
retiring arguably they are defending
their home from a foreign army in
summary the war on Yemen is a really
excellent example of how strategy is
more important than weaponry and that an
authoritarian system makes for a less
efficient army
sadly the fact that the Saudis are
losing this war doesn't mean they're not
killing people in fact the opposite is
true death toll in Yemen conflict passes
10,000 unfortunately what could have
been solved in a peaceful democratic way
has become a war of attrition that will
leave a footprint on this country for
generations to come and now the question
is do you think the Saudis can turn on
the table on this conflict or are we
going to see this conflict last for a
long time to come please do let us know
your thoughts in the comments below we'd
also like to thank Jago rodriguez for
suggesting the topic for this video
Diego is a military expert from Spain
[Music]
also please don't forget to check out
the Ricans in the media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
are not mine and also don't forget to
subscribe to our channel we publish
brand new videos every Monday and
Thursday and as always I'll see you in
the next one and if you want to learn
more about politics and here even more
of my lovely voice you can join us at
reconsider media we have a podcast at
reconsider mediacom slash podcast see
you there
[Music]